traditionally to write a document it's
right at the beginning right but if
you're writing the talk programmatically
with the Google Docs API did you know
that it's actually easier to start at
the end follow along and you'll see why
writing backwards makes it easier to
perform past requests for better
performance I when you Srivastava and
I'm going to walk you through this tip
so you can easily manage your start and
end indexes by making your insert X
request in Reverse let's look at an
example don't worry for the video we'll
start at the beginning I have a
collection of recipes that need to be
moved into Docs moving information from
a database or some other storage into a
helpful format is a pretty common issue
the natural solution is to read the
recipe information from my storage and
then write each piece into my doc where
it gets complicated is organizing the
updates here we have a lot more than
just text we have images titles heading
lists numberless it's a lot to consider
so let's start with the overview
information here we have a title and
image prep time and then lastly yield
info we'll use insert text to write the
title and then insert inline image to
add the photo and then enter text again
for the yield and prep time first let's
look at one of the requests answer text
is just a note of what text should go
where so let's try it out starting from
the beginning we write our heading
recipe and the title of the recipe so
today we're making strawberry vanilla
pancakes it's easy enough to add the
first word at index one but then we need
to keep track of how long that text was
so we can insert that next piece so the
word recipe is six characters I can then
insert the title in index seven easy
enough right but the titles will vary in
length from recipe to recipe so now we
have to keep track of each of those
we're gonna have to do this again for
every append moving on actually makes it
worse so now I need to know precisely
how long my text inserts were so that I
know we're gonna enter the photo and
then I have to remember that an image
has a length of one index no matter how
large the images so back to the
documentation this is gonna get real
tedious real fast and I'm already
worried about off-by-one errors imagine
keeping track of indexes for a really
large application where
lots of things to insert coming from
different places so here is where our
trick comes in since you have to set the
start index for every insert what if you
started from the end and always inserted
to the top of the document our batch
update insert request will look much
cleaner I'd use a single batch update
and order all of the updates in Reverse
so start at the bottom we'd start with
insert text for prep time and yield info
then insert inline image for the recipe
photo and then finally insert text for
the title and heading it's so much
simpler when everything starts at one
one batch update request contains all of
my edits listed last to first remember a
batch update is simply a container for
my list of requests so now I'm starting
at the end and finishing with a title
and no more tracking indexes writing
backwards while counterintuitive is
simpler so you no longer need to know or
even care about the length of each one
of your inserts ready to try it out for
yourself check our documentation where
we have a document structure guide that
you might find handy and let me know
what you think
happy batching everyone
you